for the past two weeks the Trump
administration has been slammed for
supposedly tepid response to
anti-semitic attacks on cemeteries and
threats to Jewish community sensors
Trump himself was smashed over and over
for suggesting the threats might be
coming from left-wing provocateur is
attempting to cast a shadow on his
administration whose lively mock for
such an assertion pretty much everyone
on the Left assumed that the JCT threats
had to be coming from Trump supporters
including the intercept the left-wing
publication that had one just two days
ago Trump can't accept his allies are
targeting Jews so he blames his opponent
and now turns out that the culprit at
one point worked for the intercept on
Friday a missouri man named juan
thompson was arrested for making
multiple threats to JCS across the
country in order to harass his
ex-girlfriend thompson is suspected of
being a copycat of hearing about the JCC
phone calls and then conducting his own
campaign of phone terrorism according to
the FBI Thompson dated a Jewish woman
after the relationship ended he sent the
Sammis where he mails and faxes to her
employer hidden stalked her after that
he may quote at least eight JCC threats
nationwide as part of his campaign
against his ex-girlfriend he then tried
to blame the woman in order to have her
prosecuted he tweeted quote know any
good lawyers need to stop this nasty
racist hashtag white girl I dated who
cents a bomb threat in my name and wants
me to be raped in jail unquote so here's
what we know about Thompson he's a
left-wing reporter who made up material
while working at the intercept he was
fired in February 2016 for fabricating
quotes in his stories and creating quote
fake email accounts that he used to
impersonate people one of which was the
gmail accounts in the name of the
editor-in-chief of the publication he
says he voted for Bernie Sanders
Thompson boys black tweeted just two
weeks ago the Trump was attempting to
quote remove black people from the south
side of Chicago naturally folks on the
right are triumphantly pointing out the
irony the guy behind the JCC threats
isn't a trump backer but a left-wing
fake news guy who hates Trump who four
weeks to what stated when for left four
weeks web stated this had to be an
outgrowth of Trump Ian anti-semitism but
let's be fair for a second the guy
sounds like a complete nut job not just
the left winger gone awry according to
the FBI this is all designed to act out
some sort of personal vendetta against
an old girlfriend who was Jewish the
Jews were only involved in so far as
they could be used as a tool against her
it doesn't make the guy's contact any
less egregious or anti-semitic but it
doesn't really seem to connect to an
ideology so much as a desire to hurt
somebody he knew by using
anti-semitism furthermore there's still
another suspect out there dozens of JT
she's have been called and the tariffs
was a copycat but but this is evidence
that while the left-wing media
constantly accuses the right of jumping
to conclusions about terrorism and
ignoring right-wing terror involvement
the left has a major blind spot for its
own extremists and you just know that
Trump's Twitter feed this morning will
be totally epic I'm Ben Shapiro this is
deven Shapiro show okay so we'll talk a
little bit more about that story i also
want to talk about these yemen raids and
what we know about them and why exactly
it's ridiculous with that the Democrats
are treating this whole thing but first
I want to say thank you to our
advertisers over at Zeile com GTL com so
I first have to tell you a story about
deal that actually happened the past
weeks my sister who lives in a major
East Coast City she was having serious
she woke up in morning she's having
serious neck trouble like so much so
that she was basically on the verge of
tears it just really excruciating so she
called my parents and my parents were
very sweet they immediately went to
zeagle calm and they booked her masseuse
for that same day the masseuse came over
and fixed right up shoes as good as new
as soon as the masseuse left that's what
zeal calm does for you they have five
star top quality massage and it comes to
your house it's not very expensive and
you can schedule it and they come
directly to you they bring the table
they bring me they bring the sense they
bring the masseuse they bring it
directly to you zo calm and if you have
a good massage we don't have time to
schedule at the spa and you don't want
to wait for two weeks and you just want
it right now then you need to go to do
calm they cost on average twenty to
fifty percent less than going to a local
spa or hotel you don't have to wait for
an appointment and you schedule you book
the payment is fast and easy even the
tip is included in the payment I've my
mother-in-law has stolen my my Neil calm
massage my sister has had one and they
both just rave about it tastes fantastic
right now you get 25 bucks off your
first massage if you use promo code been
at checkout zeel z ee l calm make sure
to add promo code at the end and use
that check out code been that make sure
that they know that we sent you and also
you get that $25 off your massage zo
calm or you can go to the iphone or
android app and a special offer when you
try zeal today enter promo code been at
checkout get that twenty five dollars
off your first in home on demand massage
at 8,000 licensed massage therapists all
across the country
and they bring the comfort to you it's
an amazing service i highly recommend it
so does my sister so does my mother of
them all zo calm promo code been ok so I
wanna start out today talking a little
bit about the facts Democrats have gone
crazy over the GM in red so a lot of
they're upset over what happened the
other night with Donald Trump in his
speech to a joint session of Congress
was at that moment with Carrie Owens who
is the wife of the Karen Owens of the
wife of ryan owens is the Navy SEAL who
was killed in this Yemen raid and the
left has been saying that is just
terrible Donald Trump used her he
brought her out there and he used her
and I got a bunch of questions about
this people who were saying that it's
just ridiculous he did use her or it's a
bad that he used her here's my view of
politicians you just be clear about this
my view of politicians using you know
victims to promote their political
agenda it's bad I don't like it I don't
know that's what Trump was doing with
Karen Owens if he was doing it in order
to get the Yemen issue off the table
yeah that's kinda yucky at the same time
what it really was with him honoring of
that and if the issue was we need to
draw closer to our vets then I'm all for
it so it's not quite the same thing as
bringing out the victim of gun violence
issue like Piers Morgan did in order to
in order to claim that everyone who
disagrees with you on gun violence is
some sort of evil person who wants
people to get shot it's more here's the
widow of a hero let's play her tribute
that's not the same thing in my mind
whatsoever but I want to talk about the
Democrats reaction to the Yemen ray
because it really is telling so here's
what you need to know about the Yemen
read let's go through what actually
happened we haven't talked at length
about this on a layout the timeline is
according to the washington post on
november seventh of last year centeno
Central Command told the Pentagon about
a plan to raid al-qaeda in Yemen the
Defense Department approved the plan
December nineteenth while Obama was
still president and the Obama
administration apparently took a look at
it then once Trump was president he was
briefed and defense secretary man is
recommended support for the Wraiths
Trump was breached a bunch of times he
finally authorized the raid January 26th
or 27th on January 28 the raid happened
apparently went wrong al-qaeda
apparently knew the Americans were
coming and attacked from a building upon
which American forces had to call in an
airstrike they were using the building
as a front basically hiding behind women
and children because that's what
terrorists do and we called in an air
strike took out the building and killed
a bunch of civilians who and when our
soldiers were in trouble we also tried
to send in in
mv-22 osprey aircraft which is like a 75
million dollar aircraft and and it ended
up crashing and we had to destroy the
aircraft so the enemy didn't get ahold
of it The Washington Post reported that
14 militants were killed terrorists were
killed as we're Owens and numerous
civilians the dead included the
eight-year-old daughter of imran ali ki
who's the the cleric that we droned
under president obama a few years ago
several female terrorist ran to plant
fighting positions opened fire on the
seals according to US military officials
Trump was in the White House during the
raid and he was tweeting during right so
what's the great objection over this
whole thing what is the grand objection
so there are two objections one is
there's an injection saying that trumps
never should have green let the raid
that it was a risky raid he did it in
order to show that he was Macho I
haven't really seen the evidence of that
Madison it it seems to me that if
Madison proves it it's totally fair for
Trump to rely on the judgment of a guy
who should know much better than he
should general mattis who has been doing
this sort of stuff his entire life and
then there is the second problem and
this is where the left says this mission
was a disaster and it was giant failure
this is the part I objective so I guess
the idea here is that if prohm could
have just rolled in the site a la Obama
and not risk American lives that
wouldn't better and that wasn't better
if specifically because no intelligence
was found so there's no controversy over
whether we found usable verifiable Intel
at this place or nuts apparently the
seals went in that grabbed hard drives
they grab laptop sing rap cell phone and
there's no an argument from weekers
versus the administration the
administration says there's intellection
there's Intel that we can use and the
leakers say there is no Intel that we
can use but here's my question why
should that matter how are the seals
supposed to know what Intel is it how's
the Defense Department supposed to know
what Intel is on the phones of the
computer they don't have the phone of
the computer if they could have hacked
them they would hack them right so they
collected the materials and somebody
died in the line of duty I don't
understand why this is why if the
mission went bad that is somehow a
referendum on the president and I don't
like this in general I really don't like
this in general because the idea seems
to be that if somebody is part of a
mission that fails somehow their life
was wasted or somehow that's the fault
of the president that the mission failed
that's pretty dangerous standard and to
be fair i think president Trump when he
was just Donald Trump was but he
promulgated this he's sort of fellow who
ripped the Bush administration and
sort of implied that we have wasted
thousands of lives in Iraq which is
really gross because here's the truth in
a war on terror in any war there will be
missions that are successful and there
will be missions that are unsuccessful
you're not of more value because you
were part of a mission that was
unsuccessful then if you were part of a
mission that was successful if you died
at the First Battle of Bull Run is a
Union soldier that didn't make your life
any less valuable than if you died as a
Union soldier at the Second Battle of
Bull Run which the Union one it's very
it's silly to try and say that if a
mission goes bad or a battle goes bad
the people who are in the bad mission
are somehow less valuable or they wasted
their lives or the batch was definitely
the fault of the presidents of the
United States as though every mission is
going to be successful war isn't science
not every operation is going to go as
planned now a lot of people on the left
there saying well you know Trump isn't
getting the sort of flak over the oven
raid that Obama got over Benghazi right
and he shouldn't because those are two
completely different things okay and
I'll tell you why there are a lot of
military missions under Obama that went
wrong their missions where seals got
killed and you really didn't hear the
the American people or people on the
right making too big an issue of it
because we understand in a war they're
going to be some missions that go wrong
that are badly planned badly coordinated
or where the crap just hits the fan but
that's not what happened in Benghazi
emang Ghazi it wasn't a mission Benghazi
was an ambassador sitting there
requesting help for months and months
and months didn't get it and then things
went bad that's not the same thing as a
military mission where we don't have all
the information they had every bit of
information it wasn't the military
attack it wasn't an attack intended to
go after the bad guys who's literally a
guy sitting in an office in Benghazi and
he was attacked by a bunch of terrorists
and the Obama administration should have
known that was going to happen and done
something to protect him or withdraw him
ASAP that's their fault so equated
Benghazi with the Yemen raid is really
illogical and quite foolish but just
demonstrates the extent to which the
left is going to go in order to push
this agenda and it's it's really I think
incredible the extent to which they'll
go in order to push their agenda the
latest example of this is the attempt to
go after Jeff session so as I said
yesterday I talked about the jeff
Sessions issue Attorney General Sessions
has now recused himself from any
investigation of Trump Russia
connections or connections between the
Trump campaign and the Russians and and
the Democrats are saying signed up for
him to recuse you should resign so I
want to go through
how this broke down because the truth is
he should recuse he should not resign
and it is very silly for the Democrats
to claim this and also the trump
administration really has to get their
commons office in order they do need to
get their communications office in order
because it just looks messy and that
feeling of chaos is not helpful so
here's how all this started flashback to
january of this year Al Franken senator
from Minnesota he asked chef sessions
during his confirmation hearing did you
have talks with the Russians and here's
what session says these documents also
allegedly say quote there was a
continuing exchange of information
during the campaign between Trump
surrogates and intermediaries for the
Russian government and if there is any
evidence that anyone affiliated with the
Trump campaign communicate with the
Russian government in the course of this
campaign what will you do senator
franken i'm not aware along any of those
activities i have been called a
surrogate at a time of truth in that
campaign and I did not have
communications with the Russians and I'm
unable to comment on it okay so people
take this there's two ways to read this
exchange one is that sessions is saying
as a campaign surrogate I did not have
contacts with the Russians and the other
is I didn't have contact with the
Russians and I was a campaign surrogate
and those are both plausible readings it
seems to me that the question was you
know if anyone from the Trump campaign
had contact with the Russians and he is
saying I never had contact with the
Russians then it turns out that he had
two meetings with the ambassador going
to serve as a sort of get critically act
which is just the typical Russian
ambassador name he's by the way
surrogate krisily act is getting more
attention this week and he will up to
the week that Putin murders him but in
any case and Stuart Smalley asked Andy
Griffith about this and you know this
becomes a big issue because the idea now
is that somehow sessions has something
to hide somehow he's working with the
Russians do something nefarious no well
I I think that that is wildly
exaggerated I don't think there's a lot
of evidence that that sessions was doing
anything nefarious are lots of senators
who've met but that's not really the
issue the issue is whether he lied about
it it's whether he covered it up whether
there was anything to cover up is
another issue
but just like in pot it seems everything
in politics now boils down to if you're
not totally transparent and forth right
at the very beginning then you get
smacked which is why it seems to me if
you can't identify any wrongdoing but
all you can identify is that somebody
you know misheard the question or
answered wrong or even if you lied you
know if you lied i guess it's perjury
and you should resign but if it just
looks like what it is which is he
answered the question as a campaign
surrogate for Trump and I didn't have
any meetings with the Russians and he
never thought well I'm a senator and I
had a meeting with the Russian
ambassador yeah that seems to me okay
recuse because it is a you know it gives
the scalp to the Democrats I suppose but
the truth is that it looks mildly
compromised so recuse let your deputy do
all the work what's the big deal but no
but don't resign but the left has to
play this over the top so Chuck Schumer
says it's not enough for sessions to
recuse himself the Senate Minority
Leader says that sessions should resign
for weeks I have said that Attorney
General Sessions needs to recuse himself
from any investigation into contacts
between the president and his associates
on the campaign and transition and
Russia for weeks I made clear that i
believe Attorney General Sessions close
relationship with the Trump campaign
requires that he recused himself from
the executive branch investigation into
ties between the Trump campaign and
Russia okay and so this is over the top
obviously because Democrats feel like
there's blood in the water now part of
the problem here is how the Trump
administration handled this so what they
should have said is sessions should have
answer more specifically he didn't do
anything wrong but to avoid the
appearance of impropriety he's going to
recuse himself that's what you handle
this instead what you end up with
because this is always the way it works
with the Trump administration they need
to get their common office in order
instead what you get is this mass
confusion before session recuse himself
so Trump comes out he says we have total
confidence in sessions and you shouldn't
recuse himself remember photo
he was himself from investigation to
beer campaign in Russia for something so
you learn that lesson spoke to the
Russian ambassador thank you that at all
where were you aware that he close to
the restroom accident it wasn't aware I
think you should have spoken to me about
whether you probably did keep an office
and I think he has a right to be grumpy
about all this because it's really silly
is really silly okay every senator has
met with chris lee act or Russian or
Russian members of the administration
Obama I guess had Chris Lee a kin to the
White House like 22 times so again
there's no underlying problem here but
should sessions have answered that he
never ever spoke with anybody from
Russia clearly not could even
misremembered jour is it a big deal no
but again Trump says he shouldn't recuse
himself and then Paul Ryan says that
sessions should not refuse himself well
okay two questions first I would just
refer to the Senate Judiciary Committee
I checked the transcript on all of that
so I can't just speak to what the
Judiciary Committee transcript is
frankly I haven't read that shirdi
communities tues and recuse himself I
think he answered that question this
morning which is if he himself is a
subject of an investigation of course he
would but if he's not I don't see any
purpose or reason to doing this and so
that's the that's the answer and it's a
consistent answer to ted cruz and he
said it's the same things a lot of
political theater and he's right so
there's a good grounds here if you're
going to say don't recuse yourself and
everybody's gonna me you're going to say
don't recuse yourself and don't recuse
yourself the problem is the sessions
then recuse himself which makes it look
like there is something more going on
it's just stupid politics they should
have come out yesterday morning and as a
body they should have said exactly what
I said right I should have said he
didn't do anything wrong but he
misremembered and that gives the
Imperium propriety he's going to recuse
himself just that everything looks
perfectly clean now before I go any
further I want to make you guys didn't
offer as listeners and Watchers of the
Ben Shapiro show doesn't offer that you
can't get anywhere else because it is
actually super duper cool would you like
fifteen hundred dollars to buy the gun
of your dreams really 1,500 bucks to buy
the gun of your dream well they need to
work with my friends the United States
yield carry association so us CCA is
changing the game for responsible gun
owners like you and me and preparing us
for everything that comes before during
and after a self-defense shooting so
they have shooting clay you know they
teach you how to use your gun is you
have to act during you know something
bad happens during some breaks in your
house how to treat that and then they
also help you with defense afterward
because just because you did the right
thing doesn't mean that you won't you
know the police won't arrest you so you
have to have people to help you out
that's what the US concealed carry
association does and you know what
they're doing right now is actually
super cool which is they want to get 10
people in my audience fifteen hundred
dollars to buy the gun of their dreams
so I've run ar-15 or if you want a
custom 1911 any gun that you're dreaming
up could be yours because over at CTA
USD CA they've started a website to send
my family now calm and you can enter for
the chance to win that $1,500 so go over
to defend my family now calm enter for
that free chance to win fifteen hundred
dollars toward any gun that you want
it's super cool defend my family now
calm and check out their membership
program there's nothing out there like
it again they have all sorts of services
that provides the gun owners in
information classes defense they're the
people that you need to talk to if you
are in as a gun owner I will say I think
USC CA the US concealed carry
association is indispensable you should
certainly get a membership you should be
working with them if you're a
responsible gun owner you almost have
responsibility to work with them plus
it's kind of cool that right now you do
have that shot to win $1,500 to buy any
gun that you want at defend my family
now calm defend my family now calm go
over and check them out the US concealed
carry association okay so sessions all
this happens then sessions finally
recuse themselves you have the entire
Trump administration again the confusion
is the part that I think is frustrating
to people they all say he shouldn't
recuse himself not going to recuse
himself and then sessions comes out and
he says yeah I guess I'll recuse myself
and my staff recommended recusal they
said that since I had involvement with
the campaign I should not be involved in
any campaign investigation I have
studied the rules and considered their
comments and evaluation I believe those
recommendations are right and just
therefore I have recused myself
in the matters that deal with the Trump
campaign the exact language of that
refusal is in the press release that we
we will give you ok so again the whole
thing looks shadier than it is just
because when you botch communications it
matters somebody needs to get that white
house press that White House
communications in order they really need
to get this crap in order because again
the more they do this the more amateur
esket looks and that's just a problem
it's a problem is going to dog them also
I would like to see a full investigation
so that we could get all of this behind
us it's either true or it's not true if
it's not true then I'd like this cloud
to dissipate and if it is true i'd like
to know it and i think we have a right
to know it okay so if you want to listen
to the rest of the show you're going to
have to go over to daily wire com watch
the rest of the show its daily wire com
eight bucks a month will gain you access
we're going to talk about more today
including the Democratic narrative about
Trump what how they're trying to destroy
Trump the Republican counter narrative
and then shockingly the media actually
sort of got it right a little bit
yesterday which we'll talk about to but
you have to go to daily wire calm for
all of that eight bucks a month makes
you a subscriber we have the Shapiro
store coming soon if you're an annual
subscriber then you're going to be able
to get a copy of free DVD copy of the
arroyo which is a fantastic movie from
Jeremy boring about what's going on it's
a southern border a fictional film
really exciting really topical the
arroyo you get that for free when you
become an annual subscriber over at
daily wire calm or listen later at
itunes and soundcloud when we upload the
entire show and make sure that you leave
a review at iTunes we are the top
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you